but we keep hearing these stories about
children being indoctrinated and they
say oh that's not happening it's not
happening veritas then finds just one
one guy one little old teacher who comes
out and says here's my antifa flag
here's my mao poster and i i tell kids
they're bad people that they disagree
with me and then they move further left
every single year and you're like these
people are real
and what you don't realize is the one
guy they caught like a cockroach you see
one of the wall yet that means there's a
thousand more behind it so for veritas
to expose the one guy is just the
beginning
there needs to be more exposure to this
but man i i tweeted this out somewhat
jokingly because you're twitter's all
jokes
it mostly is but i said imagine hating
your kids so much you sent them to
college right because like what what
happens to your kids when you center
these institutionalized learning
facilities
they shave their heads and you know put
on weird
rotted clothes so i i'm dealing with
that right now my daughter is 16 years
old she's looking at colleges she's a
very successful active junior straight
a's varsity athlete can go any college
she wants to in the country
and she wants to go to some pretty
powerful university she wants to be a
doctor which is like one of the things
that you can't do without without doing
the thing unfortunately i think you
should be able to test into that you
should be but you can't right now like
if you want to be a stock trader a tech
guy a programmer a coder a businessman a
philosopher a historian whatever you
don't have to go to college to do that
but but to be a doctor you got to do
that so so i have and i would do this
ordinarily but i am
just prophylactically like just blasting
her with as much information as i can so
by the time she does get there that she
will at least have a baseline for to
deal with this in doctrine
indoctrination have you taught her about
compound interest
we haven't talked about compound
interest just yet but i certainly will
do that right after this call but on the
topic of the sick with the antifa guy
and the project veritas thing you're
absolutely right that is just the lowest
hanging fruit that they were able to
scoop up into and to identify there have
been reports all across the country
we've got the woman uh making the kids
swear uh pledge allegiance to the queer
flag in their classroom pledge
allegiance to the queers she says this
is on tick tock it's been widely
disseminated it's not me being hateful
or anything uh there is very clear
evidence where people say well you know
what it doesn't matter that the kids
lost learning time and can read more
poorly today compared to last year
because we taught them what a riot was
we taught them what an insurrection was
we taught them what you know white
systems of oppression are so all these
people again this goes back to exactly
what the problem is in afghanistan aside
from the competing military monetary
interest is that the attention of our
education apparatus is focused on the
wrong thing
the attention of our education apparatus
is focused on making these kids into
little revolutionaries that pledge
allegiance to the queer flag that don't
care about reading and math but they
only care about learning about rioting
and insurrections and that is what is
happening so therefore every other
console every other result is is is
negative because the primary attention
is put on the wrong
thing it's rot yes it is
it is an institutional rot it is the
core foundations that make up the
country and our culture are rotting and
decaying and
no one no well they're being poisoned
they're not just rotting into decaying
they're being poisoned they're being
deliberately sabotaged
right we have saboteurs among us that
teacher is a saboteur right okay public
people argue with me but go back to the
source documents folks the public
education system in america was
established to to create a sense of
patriotism in america
this teacher is being fired this has
been this was the latest update we
haven't talked about post millennial uh
auntie of a teacher set to be fired by
school after attempting to radicalize
children attempting apparently he's been
doing it for years wow but i'll tell you
about did you look but did you see the
t-shirt he was wearing when they
confronted him oh when veritas did what
was it it was a freaking sickle
that's a tattoo dude he was wearing this
he's got a tattoo on her chest bro yeah
it's right there he's got to test it on
your chest so uh the institutional rod
let me let me tell you a story so we uh
we got we at timcast.com we're hiring a
bunch of fierce and independent
journalists best 10 bucks i spend every
month we're doing a great job and uh we
had a story
about a a truck full of modern vaccines
crashing
and there was limited for information on
it and we you know we thought it was a
big deal and so tim cast reporters start
investigating figure out what's going on
with this truck
and it's a crazy story so i tweeted like
you know we ended up learning from the
local emergency response in west
virginia where this happened that the
dod took over and and the locals were
not allowed to give statements to the
press
and i said wow
now the truth is the department of
defense works with the hhs and they have
jurisdiction over vaccine shipments so
when it happened they're like hey we're
going to be handling this
so it's not like there was a grand
conspiracy or anything and i didn't i
never said that i tweeted out something
bad happened
truck crashes carrying modern vaccine
air space gets shut down hazmat comes
out now the dod is taking over
and i guess a lot of people
immediately assume conspiracies and what
ends up happening is an article gets
written claiming
that i'm a conspiracy theorist that i
didn't accurately inform any of my
followers about what really happened
even though i posted a link to the story
now it's something i want to get off my
chest and just mention because it was it
was like an example of something
affecting me but i also think it's a
good example of institutional rot that
there is someone who knows my story was
100 true 100 factual and i never implied
there was a grand conspiracy i genuinely
was like whoa a vaccine truck flipped
over this crazy the dod's on it isn't
that crazy
we were worried
did they lose a shipment of vaccines
because they weren't telling us and then
we got a statement saying don't worry we
were able to recover all the vaccines
like oh okay i wasn't implying that like
aliens were coming or any crazy stuff
but someone had to write about it and
they had to twist it and frame it such a
ridiculous and absurd way
that people who will read that will have
their minds warped
that is just one example i experienced
recently but i'm sure everybody knows
the examples of how the media lies
cheats and manipulates like shinzo abe
and trump when he throws the fish food
in they fake it or the very fine people
hoax and so what's happening now and the
reason why i think you see
these schools focusing on the wrong
thing
is it's
the whole system of our institutions has
been twisted and corrupted by an every
you know by by the most absurd and
extreme hyper individualism
there's no national unity there's no
sense of community there's no scruples
this writer at this at this news outlet
didn't say to himself i can't write that
that's not true he went how can i twist
this in the worst way possible to get
some clicks because i don't care about
what happens to this country i don't
care what happens to my community i
don't care what happens to the people
these these schools bring these people
in and and these principals and these in
these superintendents the ones who
haven't been truly indoctrinated are
like i'm not going to stick my neck out
when this teacher does this stuff
because why should i put myself on the
line for the sake of the future of this
country our children and what ends up
happening then is over a decade of this
happening eventually the people running
institutions are in the cult and their
their minds are warped and twisted and
then they seek out more of it the way i
view this problem the easiest way to
understand it is to look up the youtube
video of hitler with a woman's body
doing tai chi with the incredible hulk
where where nursery rhymes are being
sang
because this video exemplifies the
broken fractured algorithmic dystopia
that we're living in these videos were
going viral people were making them
because the algorithm was feeding them
to babies
that is something so we as adults can
see that video and say this is insanity
why are children being fed this video
babies can't understand that because
they have no frame of reference they
just see this and that's life for the
rest of us spending 10 years going
through the broken media ecosystem the
lies the fake news and the algorithmic
manipulation
we can't tell
adults who who live in it are the same
as the babies being born into it
we can see the one thing because it's so
crazy we can't see the crazy in front of
us now obviously i think people watching
the show people like us are initiated
and what i mean by that is we're
discerning we see something and say i
want to challenge that and i want to see
how that how that stands up to scrutiny
then you look at all these people who
who all of a sudden are i tell you this
man you know breaks my heart is the
hacker community going woke
full-on authoritarian dogma and i'm like
hackers were anti-establishment
anti-authoritarian
totally like agnostic and now the whole
it's just becoming more and more woke
and i'm seeing people say here's what
you have to say here's what you can't
say and i'm like we're changing the
words of code and it's just they don't
understand they're living in this
fractured rotted and broken collapsing
system they can't see through it i agree
i agree 100 on everything you said
especially that that really uh very
descriptive phrase that you use the
algorithmic dystopia right
but there's a deeper fundamental issue
here it goes even farther back than that
and i just started to get into it a
second ago about education
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you